well Europe Europe is doing it and so is
the us right now so the US in huge
amounts of money and and Europe it
United States is doing it the European
Union is very good at saying that it
does thing things which it never
[Music]
does now although there has been a
recent fall central banks are widely
seen to have failed to control inflation
at times running up times Target the
banks blamed the Ukraine war but critics
point to the rapid rise in inflation
before the war broke out and among other
factors they often find quantitative
easing at fault moreover some claim
there's a more fundamental problem that
there is no overall coherent economic
theory in the First Place Bank models
failed to predict the 2008 crash or the
more recent cost of living crisis in
2015 the the European Central Bank
claimed that neither monetarists nor
kenian economics provided solutions to
the financial crisis leading some to
question if any economic theory had the
answers let's stop thinking of this as a
failure of the central banks to avert
inflation it is a failure of the central
bank to influence the price level and
the rate of change of price level both
on the way down so there was a failure
to arrest inflation and a failure to
arrest deflation Okay so it's not just
that
the quantity vising and money printing
gave rise to inflation it failed at the
same time to give rise to a control to
controlling deflation and the reason for
that is because when you have a crisis
like 2008 which effectively knocks out a
very substantial amount of investment in
productive activity the question is how
do you
directly replenish this investment
quantity vising failed to do this it
failed to do it spectacularly it
refloated the banking sector the banking
sector it did wonders for the finances
it did nothing for the productive side
of the economy for the supply side of
the economy and then when the war in
Ukraine conspired with the pandemics
lockdowns and so on to create a major
diminution of Supply
temporarily that combined with the fact
that some of the money that was printed
for the first time in 13 years went to
the little people through F low schemes
and so on that because of the constraint
Supply gave R rise to inflation now in
very practical terms my criticism is
that when inflation started going up I
disagree with Vicki here and I will be
surprisingly closer to John given our
politics surprisingly uh my
recommendation immediately in 2021
before well before the war in Ukraine
was put interest rates up to three and a
half% today do not go through this slow
motion of increasing interest rates at
the same time do not make the mistake of
thinking that first you have to unwind
quantity vising and then increase
interest rates increase interet R
immediately because uh Vicki the reason
why I was saying that was because yes
maybe uh you know commodity prices were
edging downwards or the inflation rate
of commodity prices but asset prices
real estate was booming you know there
was rally and everything rally in the
stock exchange it was absolutely crazy
it was important to increase to tighten
interest rates push them up to three
three and a half% immediately but at the
same time make sure that all the Lost
productive capacity was somehow
replenished especially green energy it
was as if I could see that Putin was
coming right and and and pluck the money
tree so as directly to fund directly to
fund find some scheme either through a
public Investment Bank or through some
scheme using the existing mechanism to
the central bank Europe Europe is doing
it and so is the us right now so the US
in huge amount of money and and Europe
doing it United States is doing it the
European Union is very good that's
saying that it does thing things which
it never does let me move on because a
good moment to do this I think to the
next part which is to talk about we've
talked about various theories we've
talked about central banks we've talked
about ways of stopping this lur Shee but
do we need a radical new economic theory
or should we conclude the economy is not
predictable well what I tell my students
at the
University is that uh uh they have a
duty to study every single economic
theory ever come out understand their
flaws intimately and then when it comes
to actually passing judgment forget all
of them and just retain all the
sharpness of the mind that uh this study
of eclectic study of different theories
what I am utterly against with I
actually think that they a clear and
present danger for our social economies
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or Visit ii. TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest idea
say